Well, i'm not sure that we can follow to Bobby Mc Ferrin with but we'll come up with something
The program is Notes and Neurons and.. what just happened here?
I mean Bobby Mc Ferrin said inside the stage and perform the couple of pieces of music that none of you had ever heard before
and yet you are picking up and is very clear cues and where not just understanding with Bobby what was doing
but actually becoming part of the process of making music
how do something like that happen?
how does our brain know how the process and decode the cues that Bobby is giving you?
that's credible we're going we talking about on the stage here tonight
with very distinguished panel but it course includes to my far left the one and only Bobby McFerrin
to his right is Lawrence Parsons, he is a neuroscientist at Sheffield University in the UK
Daniel Levitin is a neuroscientist at McGill University in Canada and the author of two best-selling books
'The world in six songs' which comes out in paperback the next month
and 'This is your brain on music'
and Jamshed Bharucha to my immediate left is the provost at Tufts University, neuroscientist, and
my guest just this afternoon on ...